proverb says Hope deferred makes the
heart sick when people don't have hope
when they are struggling without hope or
when the people around you lose hope for
you and therefore put you in positions
where you really are stuck it keeps you
from winning I'm amazed at what happens
when I just simply go through the
numbers with someone and go hey look if
you did this this and this you could
have this out that all paid off in in
through you know in two years three
years ago Wow I never saw that before
and you hear the light bulb come on
right over the top of their head like
it's a cartoon right and they go yeah I
can do this and you see the hope happen
or you could have a government official
that comes along and says well you
people like you are never going to get
ahead and so we have to put in a
government program because people see
that's someone who's hopeless for you
and it's gonna help you stay in
mediocrity and I got to tell you around
the financial world there's both kinds
of people there's people who will show
you how to go win and then there's
people who don't think you're gonna win
and so they're gonna make sure you stay
mediocre they're scummy people payday
lenders they charge you 800 percent
because poor people need access to
borrowed money so we're gonna Bart let
them borrow their paycheck and charge
them 800% scum right that's someone who
doesn't believe you can get ahead so
they screw you that's what it amounts to
well that goes on in the HR world as
well see we have a program called smart
dollar that goes in to HR goes into the
HR department of major companies and
minor companies and medium-sized
companies all over America millions of
employees have gone through this program
now and it came through their company
and the company says hey we're gonna
come alongside you and we're gonna put
this
class in place to show you how to get
out of debt because we're hopeful for
you we want to show you while you work
for us how you can get out of debt and
become a millionaire the opposite of
that our doobs nhr who believe that
their employees are cattle and so
they're going to be slaughtered and so
get them all in the corral they treat
their employees like cattle you ever
work for somebody treat their employees
like cattle this bull is what it is
cuz I don't care what you make you can
win in America today no pun intended
there problems right ok you mean some of
you missed that it drove right by you
yeah so listen to this this is from a
blog from one of these idiots if there's
this new phrase in HR called financial
flexibility because financial literacy
is not enough meaning if we teach people
how to handle money that's not gonna do
it the ability to manage expenses and
make everyday life affordable it is the
financial stage beyond living paycheck
to paycheck
it means being smart about how to use
our monthly income and find ways to make
our money do more so that we can pay our
bills on time because we can't live on a
budget because we don't pay you enough
financial flexibility is the stage
between living paycheck to paycheck and
financial security a level few employees
ever achieve financial security few
employees are ever no hope for you cows
unbelievable so here's what they're
doing they're doing payday lending as a
payroll deduct they'll take your check
before they give you your check and
charge you interest how awesome is this
installment loans student loan repayment
benefit programs the student loan
repayment benefit programs are all
that's where an employer pays off your
student loans for you we want to do that
all the time one get all the employers
doing that right but this idea that
they're gonna do payday lending and
these scum burgers inside your HR
department are gonna set up a thing
where instead of teaching you how to
handle money we're gonna loan you your
paycheck before you get it at a high
interest rate this is your own company
screwing you and it's all because the
little man doesn't make enough to get
ahead and so well it's just the way it
is now let me just tell you what happens
ok it's like we need to make them
comfortable they need to be comfortable
see that's what you say at hospice make
the patient comfortable give them
morphine they're dying we're gonna keep
them comfortable don't upset the cattle
we wouldn't want the cattle to think
they could get out of the corral we
wouldn't want them to think they could
stand on their own we wouldn't want them
to think they could have financial
security we wouldn't want them to become
everyday millionaires oh god forbid no
and because it's impossible for the
little man to get ahead because we just
don't pay enough we're instead gonna rip
you off again and do payday lending and
we're gonna call it financial
flexibility programs because we're
nature we have to give everything a big
name that sucks you know unbelievable
now there's great HR people all over
America that love their people and do a
good job and there's a few of you I just
called you scum straight-up
cuz you're you're stealing the hope from
your people because you didn't even have
hope for your own people and it wasn't
cuz your company didn't pay enough it's
because you don't believe that by
managing money they can get ahead and so
your answer is to screw them with a
built in inside the employer payroll
deduct payday lending program and give
it a name like financial flexibility
give me a break people the American
Dream is not dead show people how they
can win if they make more money you know
what they'll do they'll work harder so
they can get raises you know what
they'll do they'll take the overtime
it's available you know what they'll do
they'll live on less than they make
show them how to get on a budget show
them how to get out of debt show them
how working where you work they can win
we can help you do that that's what we
do is smart dollar that's why it
aggravates us when someone works
perpendicular to that and we're just
gonna make the patient comfortable
because he's terminal the patient you
know we're gonna keep him comfortable
just keep the pain down because they're
going to live in mediocrity their whole
lives ma give me a break
come on guys we got to do better than
this the little man can get ahead as a
matter of fact 9 out of 10 millionaires
started with nothing and some of them
started working in jobs that suck as bad
as working in some of your places where
you're putting this garbage out yeah
stop it
instead bring in actual financial
literacy that works financial
flexibility is not the new normal we're
not trying to keep the patient
comfortable we want the patient
uncomfortable so they can live I'm going
to keep them comfortable this is not
Hospice this is life now we're gonna
show them how to do it right and I quit
screwing your own people out there
America this is nuts